IT TO FLORIDA THE MIDDLE PART OF
THE WEEK.
>> JENNIFER GRAY, THANK YOU.
>>> TO NEW YORK CITY, PLANNING
TO OPEN EMERGENCY SHELTERS TO
HOUSE THE MORE THAN 13,000
MIGRANTS WHO HAVE ARRIVED IN THE
CITY SINCE APRIL.
MANY ARE ARRIVING ON BUSES SENT
BY TEXAS REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR
GREG ABBOTT.
IN FLORIDA, A STATE SENATOR IS
SUING TO BLOCK GOVERNOR RON
DeSANTIS FROM PUTTING MORE
MIGRANTS ON FLIGHTS TO AND FROM
OTHER STATES THAT HAVE NOTHING
TO DO WITH FLORIDA.
STATE SENATOR JASON PIZZO ARGUE
LAST WEEK'S FLIGHTING FROM TEXAS
TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD VIOLATE
FLORIDA LAW.
HE CLAIMS DeSANTIS ILLEGAL I
SPENT TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
SENATOR PIZZO JOINS US NOW.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
YOU THINK GOVERNOR DeSANTIS DOES
NOT HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO SPEND
$1.5 MILLION TAXPAYER MONEY FROM
FLORIDIANS TO DEAL WITH MIGRANTS
IN TWO OTHER STATES, TEXAS AND
MASSACHUSETTS.
BUT GOVERNOR DeSANTIS SAYS THAT
HE DOES AND HE SAYS THAT YOU AND
YOUR FELLOW LAWMAKERS IN FLORIDA
GAVE HIM THAT AUTHORITY.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAYS.
>> THE LEGISLATURE GAVE ME $12
MILLION.
WE'RE GOING TO SPEND EVERY PENNY
OF THAT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
PROTECTING THE PEOPLE OF THE
STATE OF FLORIDA.
>> SO, WHY IS THAT WRONG?
>> THE LEGISLATURE GAVE HIM $12
MILLION IN THE GENERAL
APPROPRIATIONS BUDGE ETC. OF
$109 BILLION THIS YEAR, WITH A
FEW REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE EASY
TO UNDERSTAND.
THE FIRST IS IT HAS TO BE AN
UNAUTHORIZED ALIEN.
THAT'S REQUIRED.
THE SECOND REQUIREMENT IS THEY
HAVE TO BE FROM THE STATE, THE
STATE OBVIOUSLY BEING FLORIDA.
WHEN YOU'RE PAYING FOR HOTEL
ROOMS AND MEALS AND HARPCUTS AND
$12,000 PER PERSON TO FLY THEM
WITH TWO PIT STOPS ON THE WAY TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD, YOU'RE
SPENDING FLORIDIANS' DOLLARS IN
CONTROVERSY OF THE LAW.
>> WHAT'S THE STATUS OF THE
LAWSUIT?
>> WE FILED IT LAST NIGHT.
WE HEARD BACK FROM THE JUDGE
ABOUT EXPEDITING THE
PROCEEDINGS.
IT'S NOT A TYPICAL LAWSUIT.
IT'S FOR INJUNCTIVE RELIEF.
WITHIN THE FOUR CORNERS OF A
SIMPLE TO UNDERSTAND LAW THAT
WAS PASSED THIS SESSION BY HIS
OWN PARTY, HE'S NOT PLAYING BY
THE RULES THAT HE SAID.
SO WE EXPECT IN THESE COMING
WEEKS, WE WERE HOPING FOR TODAY,
BUT IN THESE COMING WEEKS TO
STOP THE BLEEDING AND THE
HEMORRHAGING OF DOLLARS.
>> THE 50 MIGRANTS THAT GOVERNOR
DeSANTIS FLEW FROM TEXAS TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD WERE FROM
VENEZUELA.
AND THEY SAY THEY WERE FLEEING
NICOLAS MADURO, WHO THEY
CONSIDER A DICTATOR.
I DON'T HAVE TO TELL YOU THAT
SOUTHERN FLORIDA, SOUTH FLORIDA,
HAS THE NATION'S LARGEST
VENEZUELAN POPULATION.
BUT DO YOU KNOW HOW THEY'RE
FEELING ABOUT ALL THIS?
>> SURE.
MANY OF MY 550,000 CONSTITUENTS
ARE VENEZUELAN BORN, AND I
PERSONALLY KNOW A NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE SUCCESSFULLY
RECEIVED ASYLUM, THAT IF THEY
WERE RETURNED, THEY HAVE A
CREDIBLE FEAR OF BEING
PERSECUTED.
THIS IS THE ULTIMATE SORT OF
HYPOCRISY.
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS AND I SORT OF
TRACK ANCESTRAL HISTORY THE
SAME.
OUR FAMILIES CAME OVER AROUND
THE SAME TIME.
TO SEE IN SOUTH FLORIDA
ESPECIALLY, HISPANIC REPUBLICANS
FORGETTING WHERE THE LAST
GENERATION OR TWO HOW THEY GOT
HERE AND UNDER WHAT
CIRCUMSTANCES IS HYPOCRITICAL
AND SHAMEFUL TO SAY THE LEAST.
>> CNN AND NBC ARE REPORTING
THAT THERE'S A FINANCIAL LINK
BETWEEN THAT AIRLINE CHARTER
COMPANY THAT MADE THAT FLIGHT
AND DeSANTIS' BASICALLY
IMMIGRATION CZAR, THE PERSON HE
CHOSE TO HELP FIGHT HE SAYS
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
SO THAT SOMEHOW THAT MAN,
LAWRENCE KEITH, HAD WORKED FOR
AIRLINE COMPANY.
IS THAT A PROBLEM?
>> YOU KNOW, THEY GOT A
COMPONENT IN TAXES THAT IS NOT A
CRIME.
LET BE CLEAR.
OUR INJUNCTION IS VERY NARROW.
A LAW WAS PASSED THIS PAST
SESSION SIGNED INTO LAW BY THIS
GOVERNOR AND HE CAN'T CLAIM I AM
SIMPLY, NARROWLY -- A BUNCH OF
EMOTION AND PASSION, AND I'M
SURE WE'LL FIND OUT ABOUT
NEFARIOUS, CLANDESTINE
CONNECTIONS, BUT SIMPLY HE
CANNOT SEND THESE DOLLARS
OUTSIDE OF FLORIDA ON
UNAUTHORIZED ALIES OUTSIDE OF
FLORIDA.
I THINK THERE WILL BE A
CONTINUING PARTY OF CRONEYISM,
ABSOLUTELY, BUT THE SINGLE
PURCHASE FOR MY INJUNCTION
RELIEF IS TO STOP THE
HEMORRHAGING OF DOLLARS.
>> WE JUST LISTENED TO MINORITY
LEADER KEVIN McCARTHY TALKING
ABOUT THE SENTINEL CRISIS AND
HOW MANY AMERICANS ARE BEING
KILLED BY FENTANYL.
FENTANYL HE SAYS IS COMING OVER
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
IN THAT WAY, DOES GOVERNOR
DeSANTIS HAVE A POINT THAT, YES,
FLORIDA WASN'T INVOLVED IN ANY
OF THIS BETWEEN TEXAS AND
MARTHA'S VINEYARD, BUT THE
FENTANYL AFFECTS EVERY STATE AND
EVERY STATE HAS TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS AT THE
BORDER?
>> I'M A DEMOCRAT AND I'M THE
CHAIR OF THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
COMMITTEE IN THE FLORIDA SENATE.
I AGENDAED THE BILL FOR
INCREASED PENALTIES FOR OPIOID
USE AND VOTED FOR THE BILL.
I'M A LAW ENFORCEMENT GUY.
I'M LAW AND ORDER.
ABSOLUTELY IT'S A PROBLEM.
IF THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED TO THIS
LEGISLATURE TO USE FLORIDA
DOLLARS TO GO OVER THE BORDER TO
HE